Nat uh to start I think we met at an
airport
probably meant a little bit more to me
than it did to you at the time I was I
was eight and uh and you were my you
were and are my biggest were my biggest
crush in the whole world I was so in
love with you it was like and it's like
like a crazy Obsession after Charlie's
Angels and I I came up to you to talk to
you and I just completely froze and then
um you were so sweet and you said oh
thank you so much and then you went onto
the plane and I said hey mom um would
you mind if I sat with Drew and and she
said no Nat I think she's in first class
and and you were with one of the guys
from The Strokes and I was like I think
I could take that guy yeah
right here you look like a stroke now